hi mark hi everyone
wow thank you so mark is a partner
engineer at pytorch working on open
source software's production tools
including torch surf and by torch
enterprise
and mark was also an applied scientist
and product manager at graph core before
you read ai microsoft and as gpl his
primary passion is to make programming
more fun and today
mark will explain to us how to train a
model with pi torch
if you want to share your screen matt i
can then post it and then like before
you should go on your forums to answer
your questions and i've also put
the link to the collab notebook formats
talk
there
all right uh thank you so much folks for
having me uh
so yeah so
so i guess like today's talk is really
going to be
about like how to train a model with
pyth the hard way so i suspect a lot of
you may have seen
some of this content but you know rest
assured if you've never trained a model
with pytorch you'll be able to
understand the stock
and if you have trained a model with
pytorch
the the the talk is going to be
different enough and the take is going
to be more focused on the internals of
pytorch uh so you'll still get to enjoy
it so please stick around and if you
have any questions
uh feel free to let me know we'll be
just monitoring each other
so
basically this talk is going to be about
um how to train a like a model with
pythorgs the hard way
um and just like a bit about myself like
the the projects like i work on at
pytorch are like model inferencing tools
like torch serve uh model uh like ml ops
tools like tor checks and then like
long-term support branches of fire
trucks with pi touch enterprise
uh and if if you if you do enjoy the
stock and enjoyed uh you know like stuff
i'm saying you know go go ahead follow
me on twitter
uh and just feel free to dm me with any
questions you have
so what we're going to be doing right
now is just like really from scratch
we're going to just start off with
importing pythons and before we get to
training a model i just thought like uh
it'd be helpful to just discuss very
briefly like what is really machine
learning and
really the the framework we're going to
be focusing on today is called
supervised learning where you can
imagine that you have like some data
and then you want a model to make a
prediction on that on that data so if
your model is a function f and then your
data is some some variable x then the
prediction is y
and the way all of this stuff is really
going to work is that you're going to
make a prediction
but then you want to compare it to like
some labeled data so like the truth
let's call that y prime and based on the
difference between y and y prime which
is people often call the loss function
we're going to update f
and that's pretty much it so as long as
you can fit problems in this framework
you can train a model uh and solve
problems with it
and in general as a helpful heuristic
when you're trying to think about like
well what is really solvable by machine
learning
uh you can think of x as just something
being that because something that can
fit an excel spreadsheet like you know
whether uh or or or like whether it's
like a like or also like an image or
text but really fundamentally it's like
some data and then there's gonna be some
column that you're trying to predict and
that's your label
so
really though the the topic of of this
uh of this tutorial is going to be how
to train a model right but before you
train a model there's lots of stuff that
you that you can do so this is sort of
training a model is really the sort of
the last step that you should explore so
one is you could use something like an
open data set so instead of you labeling
data
you can go use something like imdb
imagenet or use something from like the
hugging face data sets uh instead of
train creating and training your own
model you could use an open model what i
mean by that is you could copy a model
architecture from some famous paper on
github
well you know not only can you just like
pick an architecture you could also take
in the model weights so as in you don't
even train a model there will be like a
pre-trained model
with things like the hugging face hub or
the or torch hub where you basically
just have a function itself and then
make an interface directly on it without
needing to worry about like updating it
uh also like lots of like tools that
make
models like libraries like fighters
easier to use like the hugging phase
training loop like the python's
lightning loop like the ignite loop like
the fast ai loop or even keras if you're
in the tensorflow ecosystem all make it
easier to do this and so what we're
going to do is really going to unpack
like how these trainers like actually
work and how you'd implement them and
draw a pytorch so like i said this is
going to be like the focus of the stock
will be how to train train a model
so fundamentally though like but before
we start talking about like how to do
machine learning
um
a lot of these training loops look
something like this you'll have some
sort of model and then you want to fit
it on some data
right then you have like tools like auto
ml where you don't even worry about the
model you just like fit some data
and then like pre-trained models where
you know like you just essentially
fine-tune on something so that would
effectively be like calling something
like that
uh so this loop uh so let's just show
you an example of what this looks like
so for example i'm just going to i'm
going to install transformers here very
quickly
um and what we're essentially going to
do here is we're going to use a model by
the by the deep set ai team so they have
a mini lm model so this is a small
language model on a question answering
data set
so as you can see i'm literally just
downloading the the model here but also
downloading like a tokenizer for it so
as a tokenizer is because
essentially neural networks like don't
really understand like what a sentence
is right so for example let's say we
want to ask the network a question like
is mark clear so we want to tokenize the
sentence into a bunch of numbers that a
neural network can understand
um
essentially the way this tokenization
will work this is like a wordpiece
tokenizer so it'll take basically every
word
uh in that sentence
but then
what we really want to do is return
tensors from it so we want to make sure
that these are all
basically data that the neural network
can understand and so this is exactly
what this looks like we're going to
tokenize this sentence
and we're going to basically and then
we're going to make the model do an
inference on that sentence
and essentially here the model is going
to make a whole bunch of predictions and
we want to find the most likely
prediction so we're going to do an arg
maxwell for all the predictions and it's
going to say no mark is not clear
actually what is my name though because
this is a yes or no model but
uh so so this is sort of like the
general idea behind this is that you can
think of your model as just a function
on top of some data so that takes in
some data and gives you a prediction out
and so the question will be
how does how do you train a model like
this
so before we start talking about pytorch
it's helpful to just go like you know
back to like the titans on which
everyone everyone stands on and that's
something like psychic learn
so imagine that you have some data and
then this data is literally just like uh
on on a 2d plane so you have the
0.11.12.2.23
and you want to basically fit a line on
this data
all right
so
so so so the question is here well you
know how do you do this and so if you
want to fit a line like one way to do
this within uh scikit learn is to just
call like linear regression and remember
fit and then so x is the is the training
data and then why is the
are are the labels
so we we train a model and then let's
say you want to get the accuracy for it
you know turns out that it's a perfect
model but then if you actually want to
figure out like the so the quote-unquote
like model weights uh this would be like
one two and then the intercept so this
is basically
the the a's right so if you have like y
is equal to a x plus b so a is a vector
in this case and then b is a value and
so this gives you like the function but
trying to get back to this analogy when
we were talking about like a model just
a function in this case if you said like
for example i want to predict the value
of
the 0.35
then this would just here in this case
like return a single uh single value of
16. so again so in this case like we
have a function
that takes in like two-dimensional data
and returns a one-dimensional output
label
um it has weights as in you know this is
one two so let's say imagine you save
those to disk and then you can load them
again and now someone else can use this
model you can deploy this model uh so
very much so like you'll notice like in
in frameworks like pytorch
uh that you can think of like your model
as being like a data and a function as
in its data when you save it but it's a
function when you're doing an inference
on top of it and this is a very powerful
framework to think about it
so
back to talking about like training
loops you know so here for example in
this case with scikit-learn we had this
like linear regression.xy
uh but let's say we use a framework like
fightridge lightning but again like the
same idea applies to whether using the
face trainer ignite keras fast ai like
the same idea all applies
um so we're gonna have like some model
and we'll describe what that is in a
second and then what you're basically
gonna do is call a trainer fit on a
model
and some training data loaders so this
is some data and then validation data
loader just to make sure that you're not
over fitting on your input data
um but it's sort of the same idea right
like model data so what's a training
data loader well a training data loader
could be something like it so in this
case it's a function that is that
applies to some data so for example
it could be like
like here so let's just go over this
example so let's say you have a csv data
set or an s3 bucket or some binary data
or links to images or whatever
you want to be able to for example like
load in a few examples at a time so
instead of just like making the trainer
take in some raw data you make it take a
function that has access to that data
but can put it in a nice enough format
for your trainer to work with
uh so there's a whole bunch of data
loaders that exist uh like a recent one
is like python also has a data loader
that works well with like sort of
internet data as an ns3 bucket where
you're streaming stuff
uh so definitely a super convenient uh
way of working with data
so
this is how the like so here remember so
there's like to really understand this
function the strainer.fit function
there's two parts there's the model part
and then there's the training data
loader part and then there's the fifth
part right so so actually sorry three
parts so we covered retraining data
loader next let's cover the
sorry
yeah next let's cover the fifth part
right so the way this works is so
remember like when we described like
machine learning in plain english like
you make a prediction with some model
and then after making that prediction
you want to see how different that
prediction is from the actual example
uh and then once you know what that
difference is you update your model so
this is this is going to be exactly that
so you have this first like training
step here so first off like we're going
to be iterating over like examples
uh from the data set
um you're basically going to figure out
like well
how different was my prediction from
from from the prediction of the model so
this is what this training step is
then you're gonna basic so sorry uh so
so this is just figuring out uh
figuring out an inference
and the backward step here what you're
gonna do is figure out like uh how by
how much should you change your model
weights and then apply this change in
model weights here
so if this seems complicated this will
make a lot more sense when we're
discussing like real code like this is
just pseudocode at this point but again
in plain english the way to think about
this is you want to figure out how wrong
your model is that's your loss you want
to figure out by how wrong each layer is
so that's lost backwards and then you
want to update your model so that's
optimize your dot step
so
understandably so you may think at this
point like well you know like
why should i bother to really train
models from scratch like i can just use
a pre-trained model i don't have to
worry about any of those and you're
right like i mean for 99 use cases like
that's definitely true but there's a few
reasons why you may want to train a
model from scratch so the first one
could be well you know if you're using a
pre-trained models and and you know you
have a whole bunch of failures with it
it'll help you debug things more easily
also you can do ml research more easily
sometimes you don't have a choice like
let's say let's say the kinds of model
or the kinds of data sets that you're
working with just don't exist and need
to do everything from scratch and fourth
that's fun you know it's it's a fun
skill set that can help you get paid a
lot so it's definitely like worth worth
investing more in it
but really you should think of this as
being like over time you want to make
sure that like machine learning model
training doesn't become sort of like
this arcane like knowledge that like
only a couple of majors like know about
like it's actually
not that tricky like once you get to the
basics of it and hopefully the stock
like makes a lot of those points a lot
more obvious to you
so
great so we've done all of this you know
this last 15 minutes was all
introduction
and really you know now we can finally
start talking about pytorch so what what
is phytarch what's the difference
between python scikit-learn so the main
difference is that like pytorch is
what's called the tensor computation
library
uh with strong gpu acceleration so
tensor computation means it's not that
different from numpy but with strong gpu
acceleration it's like one
distinguishing feature
and the other main feature is it adds
facilities for
tape based autograd systems and again
this is just like a very fancy way of
saying that you can take a model and
then figure out like how wrong each of
its layers are without necessarily
having to do like a whole bunch of
calculus for yourself so so this is sort
of like the main the primary benefit of
python
so let's go over an example right so
let's say uh so all pytorch models need
to inherit from a class called like
torch n module
and then they'll have an init function
and a forward function
uh so in the forward function here
you're gonna see that well we have this
linear layer and then what we're calling
a non-linear layer and then a linear
layer and a non-linear layer the reason
we do this is because if you have two
linear layers one after the others
they'll just collapse into a single
linear layer and if it was just a single
linear layer you know great you end up
back with linear regression so the
example we just covered so the main
difference with deep learning is one it
adds non-linearities and we'll this will
i'll show you in a second like how those
work
um
and it uh sorry as linearities and then
it also adds like non-linearities and
then it has like facilities for you to
do auto grad on top of it so so you
don't need to think about how to update
the weights of this model
uh and if you're just wondering like
okay well what do you mean by these
linear layers and activation layers
the linear layers here are for example
torch and then linear
and this is literally just linear
regression example and then torch relu
and softmax and i'll show you in a
second like what those are in a second
but you know we have this model
right it compiles
and then great so so now we so now we
have this model here so let me just show
you what this looks like so if you print
it
right you like so so this is like what
the model looks like stereo light so
this is sort of the data structure that
you're working with
so
you may have heard of other kinds of
layers you so you may have heard of
things like attention rnns
you know recurrent neural networks
convolutional neural networks
but you know they're all sort of almost
like special cases of linear layers so
that's why i'm really covering it here
so attention for example and uh so
attention is really just like includes
like three linear layers and there's
like other other better talks that go
over like how this works exactly
recurrent neural networks also include
linear layers and convolutional neural
networks aren't really up front they
don't really look like linear layers but
you can implement them as such
and the reason why we have different
layers just to be clear is because they
have what's called like different
inductive biases as in
that's just a fancy term for their good
certain kinds of tasks like cnns are
good at finding like information in a
space rnn's good at remembering stuff
attention is like i guess i just want to
go to everything
but foundationally in terms of ops like
like thinking in terms of linear layers
will help simplify this like quite a bit
uh quite a bit for you think about these
for the first time
okay so yeah so so here we printed a
model and you know just the thing to
keep in mind here is that really what
we're doing is very much like uh matrix
multiplication so
let's just like look at the thing like
very quickly so we have this linear
layer and it's saying okay it's taking
an in features a hundred so that means
it's taking in a vector
it's taking in a vector of size hundred
but then it has like these hidden
features like the odd features
and then features that are higher
dimensional
that way you can sort of represent your
problem using more than just like 100
weights at the very end you'll notice
that it has like this out features 10 as
in let's say we're predicting like one
of 10 classes like one of 10 possible
animals so this is where this shows up
and the soft max is really just a way to
pick the best like basically the best
feature among those ten
uh right so let's say each of those ten
will be a number and i'll show it to you
in a sec
and then you just like want to pick it
so again the way to think about this is
what is your input size
output size like basically the hidden
feature size is basically how much
compute can you afford how much storage
can you afford odd features is
determined by your problem like how many
classes you have and then you're gonna
have some nonlinear function like the
softmax that helps you pick the most
likely cost uh so just to show you like
there's no black magic here like let's
say we had the relu
for example and like what does this do
right so let's say we we generated this
like random tensor that's a very useful
function and so it's like around n so it
generates a random temperature of size
four
and what the relative is going to do is
it's basically going to zero out all the
negative values so here you see these
two are negative so these are going to
be zero
uh and then this one remains unchanged
right so this is just like a way of
getting rid of negative values and make
sure that like your models are more
likely to converge
as far as soft max goes
uh notice here so so i said this thing
earlier that like soft mac helps you
pick the most likely value
and again that sounds like it's a bit
like black magic but the way to think
about it is that let's say you have
four possible values for like a
prediction
and what you want to do is you want them
to become a probability distribution so
you want the sum of all of those values
to be equals to one and then you would
basically generate the random number
between zero and one and pick one of
these
uh and then you'll see here that if you
sum them up it's actually pretty darn
close to one it's just it's floating
point numbers so it's gonna be hard for
them to sum up to one but this is how
you would get the max right so then
let's say you want to figure out like
which of those values does your model
predict you would do something like
mp.rgmax on top of the sum and it would
tell you for example that the most
likely prediction is this guy right here
so like label zero right and then label
zero could be in cat dog or whatever
else so there's another key value story
that you would have to keep track of
these things
so let's just quickly go over like what
how these look like exactly
um so the so there's this nice library i
i like called like a rich that shows you
like how to inspect modules and the
torch functions are the same so for
example relu here you want to apply a
rectified linear unit function element y
so this means element wise means you're
applying a function on each element of a
tensor
uh and there's like vectorized versions
there's like broadcasting there's all
this cool stuff that we can talk about
but in general like
looking at the docs honestly really
helps sometimes to figure out how
something works whereas like with torch
linear the way that works is it's saying
you apply a linear transformation to the
incoming data so you have y is equal to
x a transpose plus b so a is a vector
let's say how many inputs you have and
then b is some sort of bias
just so that you can like move around
the function and then y would be your
label in this case so again looking at
softmax here so it's saying it applies a
softmax function to an n-dimensional
input tensor rescaling it so that all
the elements are in the range zero to
one and sum to one
right
again remember now like back to this
model right here
this tiny model that's a toy model that
we have
um
remember when i said that like like
models are functions but they're also
data so let's say i want to print the
values
that are like in these weights like you
can just literally print them like this
you can just say four parameter
model.parameters
and you can just like print them and
like visually inspect them to see what's
going on like maybe you have lots of
nands which is like that
right
but you could also like look at for
example the parameters for a single
weight so for a single layer so let's
say i want to say four modeled upper
amps oh sorry
yeah getting lost here yeah so for
model.linear one so linear one was the
first linear layer you can also look at
the perhaps but any layer is sort of the
same and so again and that means you can
save it you can load it and so this is
how like a lot of ml ops gets done and
that like you train a model you save it
you load it again you can use it for
something else
uh and the reason is because like again
it's it's both data and the function
so
you know like i said there's all sorts
of other architectures like transformers
cnns or current neural networks and you
can sort of dream your own and a great
way to actually learn pytorch is to go
ahead and try to implement one of those
things like from scratch right like and
just see what would it be like let's say
so right now we're with our hugging face
like hugging face course so what would
it look like to implement like a really
simple example of like an attention
layer and you can sort of do this like
building it up with with uh with linear
layers but obviously like a production
ready version would include like so much
more stuff but at least it gets you like
more familiar with the basics
so
other things like so let's say we we we
talked about soft max which is
a way to to to make sure that the values
in a vector all sum up to one but
there's a whole bunch of other ones for
example there's one called like a gallo
and then just like looking at this thing
you know you could be like okay well you
can sort of try to understand like how
some of these things work there's like
the swish function
uh also the same and and the nice thing
about experimenting with ml so back to
the tiny model here
uh machine learning is inherently like a
very empirical science right so instead
of like let's say trying out a soft max
here maybe you could try out a gelu
maybe you could try out a swish you
could come to the linear layer make it
bigger you could change it to a cnn you
could choose rnn so it's like very lego
based so try things out and then you can
just see what works best on your problem
domain and if you don't have time or
don't have the expertise to do so
that's where using pre-trained models
like really really helps
all right
excellent
so
now like i guess it's time to talk it
like you know in a bit more detail as to
like what is a tensor exactly so let's
say we have this thing called a so it's
going to be a torch around then so that
means it's going to have five elements
and then they're going to be allocated
on the cpu so let's inspect this for a
second and see what's interesting here
so one you'll notice like data has a d
type here so d type means it's a
floating point 32 this could have been a
floating point 64 as well
uh the reason i want to talk about like
d types here is because
um
let's say for if you're using like
nvidia gpus then you may use something
like a floating 16 if you're using like
an intel cpu you may want to use
something like int8 so turns out like
precision as in like very precise
numbers doesn't really matter
drastically for machine learning so you
can use lower precision bits and take
advantage of hardware acceleration so if
you want to take advantage of that kind
of hardware acceleration like all you
would really need to do is come in here
for example and let's say
add in like d type
uh equals uh like torch dot intake
uh and that's pretty much it you know
like you you like
pie charge takes care of the rest for
you but there's other also interesting
so for example like mkl or ort so for
example is it using like the onyx
runtime environment is it using some
acceleration by intel is it using vulcan
uh what's the layout of the tensor is
like like is there like a specific way
it's laid out into memory does the
tensor have a name what's the type like
maybe it's a complex tensor because
you're using doing something with music
like what's the shape and what are the
actual values inside of it so this is
like the tanks are sort of like the main
main data structure that you're going to
be working with
and again just looking at its arguments
will give you a lot of ideas as to like
what's available and what you can what
you can do with it
so back to how to make an inference
though so let's say you have this
network right and now
we want to print it like again this is
what this model looks like and i want to
just generate so here it says in
features is equal to 100 so i'm
literally just going to generate random
data so input is random
and then i'm going to make an inference
here and i'm going to print the output
right so
this is sort of like when you're
thinking about like what is like
inference or you know just
like you you have some data and you want
to pass through a model like this is the
way it works and this is how you would
know like what the input dimensions are
so that's pretty much it right but let's
say now like well we're doing
classification right so we want to
figure out like what is the maximum
value between these things so we know
okay that the largest value
is this like one three two five here
and that this corresponds to index one
because it's a zero index
uh and this is how you can end up making
a classification from just like the
super simple prediction on raw data
uh but in of itself you know this is not
super interesting because we just have
random model weights
on some random data and we got like you
know so we have garbage into garbage
garbage so like none of the none of this
is interesting so far but it shows you
again like how the framework works and
now we'll do something a bit more useful
here
so remember when i talked about
that
when you're trying to train a model with
pytorch like the things that you need to
think about are your model so your model
includes like some layers
so these could be linear layers they
could be cnns they could be rnns etc
it includes your activation function so
like maybe it's soft max
your goal which really you can think of
as being the loss
as in like i want you to for example
make these accurate like like
predictions well this formula the
categorical cross entropy like really
helps but you could have like all other
kinds of formulas
uh that that you know make more sense
for your use case and then the optimizer
you can think about it as how can you
achieve your goal so
the main the most popular way
is what's called like stochastic
gradient descent but there's other
algorithms like atom then there's a
whole literature on optimizers and most
of the reasonable ones already exist
like in pie charts so you can again just
try them out and see what works best for
your use case
so in terms of here of an optimization
what we're going to do is we're saying
okay we want to do a classification so
that's why we're using cross-entropy
loss
and we want to perform stochastic
gradient descent on
this network basically the net dot
parameters we want a learning rate which
basically tells the model like how
quickly it should update its weights so
for example if it's converging too
slowly you make this value bigger if
it's converging too quickly or if it's
too chaotic then you make the smaller
and then a momentum is also like
slightly more advanced concept but that
also helps with convergence
so remember when we talked about like
pythorg here so we said for example
that you know if you want to generate a
random tensor that's like let's say of
size 2 it's going to generate two values
but let's say we want to generate a
tensor of dimension three two
so this basically means you're gonna
have like uh
like three tensors that are of dimension
two stacked one on top of each other
uh so another way to do this could be
like you know let's say instead of it
being a dancer it could just literally
be like a list right and you just like
append them one on top of each other
but the benefit of doing things in a
batched way is that like now let's say
you're mate you want to make three
inferences
instead of like let's say adding like a
model dot out on a for loop you could
basically make a batched example and
then you have a single operation that
can run like really fast like on gpus
so this is again where the numpy with
gpu collaboration pitch of which comes
in
most numerical linear algebra libraries
also come in with like a bunch of nice
stuff so let's say
we have this batch here and so this is a
matrix of size like three by two
uh and then we're going to multiply it
by a value two right but two isn't a
matrix right so so if you said three by
two times something of size one like
that operation should fail but partridge
here understands like what you mean and
what it does it'll broadcast these two
into a vector for you and then multiply
each of those elements like by two for
you because it's sort of like understood
like what you're trying to do here
uh right so again like like this so so
this is like where
using a linear algebraic really helps
like whereas like you know you could use
for something like python lists but
you're probably going to have to
reimplement all this nice stuff from
scratch you may not have like the nice
like gpu acceleration you're not going
to have like all the core apps like
either an 810 or a plus or etc like
implement it for you and you can just
like work in python as opposed to
working like with t plus plus functions
or fortran functions which is like you
know not super fun
um
so back to this batch example
so
let's say let's say i create an example
that's like now three by one
and then i have like let's say this is
my b batch and then my a batch was two
by three so because the dimensions match
and the inner dimensions match you can
multiply these two things
so one of the reasons why gpus are so
important for machine learning is that
they're very good at taking in like
these large batches and multiplying them
very quickly with specialized kernels
uh so thankfully i mean like gpus aren't
like that expensive anymore like
especially like with something like
google call up like all i really have to
do here is come in here click on edit
notebook settings
choose a hardware accelerator as a gpu
and we are pretty much uh good to go
um so let's say okay so so now let's try
to do like a like more of a real use
case where let's say we have a bite size
of five and then we have ten classes so
now like the random tension that i'm
generating let's say again like i
haven't changed my network like my
network still takes in an input size of
a hundred i'm gonna say okay well you
know you also need to be taking in a bad
size of five so i'm gonna have 500 size
sensors like stacked one on top of each
other
i'm gonna put them on a device called
cuda so that basically pytorch knows
like okay you're gonna do something on a
gpu
i'm also going to say requires gradient
equals to true here
uh and then i have like my target here
which is basically going to be let's say
like the d type is going to be torch
long in this case and then i'm going to
generate like 10 number of classes
because i'm going to generate like 10
random labels
and then the way by torch would know how
wrong i am is essentially here with this
function so like if you go back to
criterion
right so criterion here is the cross
entropy loss right so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take the cross
entropy loss between
my what my inputs suspect
and what my targets are so basically my
inputs and how wrong i was
so just to quickly sanity check and look
at some of the shapes here
so so yeah so this this may take a while
let's see here am i on gpu
maybe you should have made this smaller
let's see i ran this before anyway like
so while this runs like let's just give
it a second
okay it ran great so you'll see here
that the targets.shape for example
is going to be here so let's see number
of classes
see targets.shape
so here the targets of shape is going to
be
there's going to be bat size many
examples
so basically we're going to have like
five examples that we're predicting from
right
the input shape is going to be the batch
size times the input size so 500 and in
this case you'll see the loss is
actually a number so this is a number
that tells us like how wrong we are
and
you may have guessed that you ideally we
want this number to be as close to zero
as possible and this is exactly where
you know now like the the training part
really starts
so
let's do this so we have this tiny model
and i'm gonna send this model to the gpu
then i'm going to have a criterion so
i'm going to say okay i'm going to do a
classification
i'm going to have my optimizer i'm going
to do 5000 epochs so basically i'm going
to go over my data 5000 times
and pretty much all python training
loops look some something like this
first
make sure that you basically zero out
like how wrong you were from earlier
that's what the optimize your regret is
you calculate your current output so
this is what's called the forward
propagation
you figure out how wrong you were
you get the gradients on how wrong you
were
and then you basically apply and update
your weights
and then you start printing the loss and
ideally you want the sloths to go down
so let's see if this actually works
okay for example here we're starting
with a loss of 232
229 where we go yeah so we started with
232 229 222 213 1.97 so you'll notice by
the way that even though we did 5000
epochs and all we're doing is training
on a single example like basically a
single like fake example
and we have a model
that has like like a hidden layer of a
thousand even then we weren't able to
get the training loss to zero so
generally doing random data helps
because it helps you debug errors before
you start working with real data and it
just goes to show you how hard some of
this stuff is and like why you should
maybe sometimes consider using a
pre-trained model or using like an open
model with like no with things that are
known to work
so how would you make this loss zero
well you know maybe just try more epochs
maybe try making the layer larger maybe
try adding more hidden layers maybe try
adding like different kinds of layers
and just try stuff try stuff try stuff
and eventually you're going to find
something that works and maybe you'll
learn something new out of it so again
because ml is a very empirical
uh discipline
the faster you get that experimenting
quickly the better you're gonna get that
learning what actually works
so this was as far as the training loop
goes i'm gonna i'm going to repeat it
like you zero out how wrong you were
from earlier
you figure out like what is your current
prediction how wrong that current
prediction is
you apply how wrong you are on dead then
later on on each of the layers
you optimize your model and then you
basically print out the loss and then i
you want that to go down so this is this
loop will serve you well and everything
will sort of like look like this unless
you're using a training loop then you
know you obviously won't see this
because someone else would have done
this for you
um so let's talk a bit about gradients
right like how does this magic work
right so we had this thing on optimize
zero grad we had lost backwards
and we add optimizer that stuff and
really the point i want to make to you
is that there's no real magic to this
like as in
uh instead of using the categorical
cross entropy loss like i could have
just computed this loss myself and then
i have seen okay well i have the sloths
it's on this device etc
uh and and even then like when you're
thinking about this optimizer.step
function
really the way it looks is like this
like you basically
uh you go over a bunch of epochs
you figure out like basically some
gradient on a vector you apply a
learning rate and then you sort of
successfully apply it over and over
again so it's an iterative algorithm
so again like
none of this is any black magic
but
let's talk about a bit about the black
magic which is really automatic
differentiation so let's assume let's
forget like the tiny model for a second
uh and let's assume that you have
something that looks like this which is
uh you have
you have uh let's say here so let's say
we have a tensor that's just like
2 3
and then this tensor that has like the
values like 5 6 and then we're going to
create a tensor so that's basically
3a
plus b times a
right so this is a function
so before we run this let's look at a
bit about like the calculus for it so
let's say we have 3a plus ba let's say
you want to derive this with respect to
a
then you know you have 3a then that's
three and then ba so then the derivative
is b
so then you know that the end value is
going to be 8 9. but now let's say
you're deriving this with respect to b
well this is 3a is not a function of b
so it's going to be 0.
and then here it would just be a so then
you know great then the value is just 2
3. so let's just confirm that that's
actually what python does
so here we're going to basically
have a place to deposit the tensor so
think of it just like as a data
structure where you're putting the
gradient updates and then we're just
going to say c dot backwards
and when you do that you're going to
notice okay so it's eight nine two three
and that matches exactly like eight nine
two three here
okay so this is it's complaining because
i'm doing it i'm doing this twice but
this is fine
uh so again like
when you're thinking about how to use
fighters for automatic differentiation
part of it is that like if you have a
large complicated model computing all
the derivatives for it is really
annoying to do it by hand so you can
sort of convince yourself that it works
on some simple functions but if you have
like much more complicated what's called
computational graphs like neural
networks
this is where using an autodesk engine
will really really be helpful but you
can always stand at each check like what
are what are the derivatives exactly if
you look at a.grad i just standardly
check them by hand to make sure that
everything works great
so once you've done this like you you
finally trained a model like success
what you could do is you could just save
it with like you can just say like net
dot state ticked and save it to some
path
uh and then at that point it'll just be
like data that's stored on disk so you
can upload it in s3 bucket you can put
it in azure blob you can send it to your
friend via email on dropbox or whatever
and then what they could do is they
could call torch download and load it
and then if they were to print it
yeah great like they just saw like the
exact same model that you got and then
they could again do for you know load
for param and loaded model.params
uh and get exactly the parameters are
and then call loaded model on an input
and do it for whatever they could call
it and then fine tune it so again this
data as a function paradigm is really
the one thing you could take away from
the stock is that uh will help you
really really like under aggravate how
this stuff works
so that's really the the main thing i
want to cover today and i really want to
end like with a slightly more advanced
feature uh it's been very exciting which
is torch fx so
pytorch even though like as a user
you're mostly using it you're mostly
using python but python is actually
mostly written in c plus plus because it
helps us like memory manage and write
things in a more efficient way in
general one exception to this is fx so
what effects is
is essentially a way to write compiler
passes
over pytorch modules in python
and the reason this is very powerful is
so let's let's go over an example here
so we're going to basically load then a
model
and what we're going to do is we can
you'll see here we literally have a for
that it's like oh for node and
graph.nodes and what we're going to do
is we're going to say if node.target is
equal to linear.1 linear one make it
linear too right so what is this
effectively let's look at the model
again so we have linear one we have
activation then we have linear two and
then we have softmax
so what we literally did here is we
skipped those first two layers
and created the new model and now this
new model we can save it we can fine
tune it right so again this is sort of
just the tip of the iceberg but i really
wanted to show you this example because
you could do all sorts of stuff like
maybe you want to export your model to
some runtime like tensor rit or rt maybe
you want to quantize your models as in
change the d type to an intake or
float16 maybe you want to do something
like extract intermediate
representations of a model maybe you
want to fuse two operations so if you
have two operations that show up a lot
next to each other you can create one
single operation that's much faster and
there's a whole bunch of stuff you can
dream up so this is probably a very very
fruitful area where you can think about
how to innovate within the pie church
ecosystem
so like really in conclusion
um you know maybe in the not so distant
future like model.fit or just like
model.finetune will be all that you need
uh and at that point like knowledge of
how to train networks from scratch like
maybe lost
uh but you know but what i'm really
hoping is like let's say you know like
the force the four horsemen of the
apocalypse like descend upon us and that
we lose all pre-trained models and that
we lose like all open data sets is that
like the knowledge of how to train like
models from scratch gets maintained
that you'll still use it that you'll
still build innovative stuff with it
um
and at this point you know you may think
great like this was uh
this was maybe a great or maybe not so
great like introductory talk as to how
to use spy torch
so if you're really
interested in learning more about pie
tarts what i would highly recommend is
you read the docs the docs are great
probably some of the best tutorials and
the other step is reading good code so
there's lots of good code around like
whether it's by people like phil wang
like ross whiteman with matthias faye
but also highly recommend you just check
out like some of the source code for
hugging phase for fast ai you'll learn a
ton about how to write like by touch
and and even then if you're thinking
great like i'm i want to do some more
advanced stuff or maybe i even want to
work at pie torch uh probably the best
way to contribute to pie chart
is to solve issues on github so we have
lots of issues tagged with beginner or
boot camp tasks so you can check those
out and you can create like a cool
project with this so try to basically
create something cool to get like the
attention of a pie charts developer but
really most importantly is like follow
the gradient of your interest like as in
like this is a big field there's a lot
of interesting stuff you could do so
if you do something interesting you're
much more likely to do something else
that people find interesting and you
know if
if you have something cool and you want
feedback on it like feel free to dm me
i'm more more than happy to
uh share feedback on it
um and yeah and i guess that was it for
me thank you so much folks if you have
any questions i'd love to thank them
awesome thanks a lot mark that was a
super comprehensive tour through i'd say
almost all of ml
um
in fact it reminded me a bit of jeremy
howard's uh what is torch and then
really he has a super nice tutorial on
the pie torch uh docks where he kind of
deconstructs all this stuff from scratch
and i i sort of saw you also channeled
richard feynman at the end
where he had a similar analogy in
physics that you know imagine we lost
all knowledge what would be the one idea
that you would like people to remember
and he was like you know matcha is made
of atoms and for you it's like
know how to train neural networks from
scratch so
yeah i definitely i'll say probably
matrix multiplication and autodesk i
think those ideas would help us rebuild
significant chunks of civilization but
thank you like i don't think i'm worthy
of those compliments but thank you
so i think we've got time for like a
couple of questions um so one thing here
was um you mentioned at some point this
uh sort of kind of technical detail
about
i'm not needing high precision bits in
machine learning or maybe deep learning
particular could you sort of expand a
little bit what why is this and you know
why should i care
sure yeah so uh i mean so this is maybe
more historically
but if you can imagine like maybe the
first like scientific use cases of
computers historically
uh were things that were very calculus
heavy so imagine like ballistics like
nuclear simulations so hard science
stuff and typically in hard sciences
like the lower precision bits really
really matter like because if you're off
like by a bit you know like your rocket
like won't land
you'll attack someone you don't want to
attack so it's super important
uh in machine learning like just
uh it's like i don't know if i have a
good theoretical argument as to why this
is the case like all i can say is
anecdotally
if you do try to deploy some model or
train some model with lower precision
bits they tend to do
you know not that much worse than the
higher precision ones
the benefit of it though is that you're
definitely losing some performance but
you're gaining more in terms of hardware
acceleration so like hardware providers
will give you like better kernels to do
things really really fast so it's
definitely a conscious sacrifice that
you're taking
but for a lot of people it's worth it
and it could be worth it for a few
reasons like let's say for inference you
just want your influence to go faster
because you're doing real time so that's
a great reason to use lower precision
but even for training like let's say
you're debating between okay i want to
train for one week with floating point
32
or train for you know one week of
floating point 16 so i'm effectively
doing twice the amount of training
you know that may be worth it because
just like time is limited on this earth
right so only rare resource that we have
and so it's just a thing to consider so
the argument is purely as far as i'm
concerned like anecdotal but i'm sure
some people are smarter than me know
some theoretical reason why that's the
case
awesome thanks
so i think we hit the time um so thanks
again once uh for for giving this
awesome talk and um thank you for
contributing to the to the course
community event
well thank you thank you so much i
really appreciate it thank you for
listening everyone appreciate it